On a un vent sud-ouest à 20 km
à l'heure. Il ne devrait pas y
avoir de changement de ce côté.
Des conditions parfaites pour un
décollage. Je pense avoir
entendu que l'on décollait beau
temps, mauvais temps. On a ce
que je vous disais, un ciel
généralement dégagé avec un vent
ce que je vous disais, un ciel
sud-ouest c'est pas mal mieux
que chez nous.
- Les images en direct du
cosmodrome à Baïkonour.
On voit les deux bras, les tours
qui descendent tranquillement.
On est à quelque chose comme une
trentaine de minutes maintenant
du lancement. J'en profite pour
vous dire qu'on attend aussi le
point de presse de l'Agence
spatiale canadienne puisqu'on a
réuni tout le monde, tout le
monde est là probablement ce
matin pour voir cela. Il y aura
des représentants, une future
astronaute canadienne qui
prendra la parole à ce moment-là
pour s'adresser à tous ceux qui
suivent cela de près ou de loin,
au Collège de Maisonneuve,
l'alma mater de David Saint-
Jacques, au Collège de Montréal
aussi on suit cela. Ces
préparatifs, on a vu reculer,
c'est étonnant, pourquoi c'est
le programme russe et on décolle
du Kazakhstan? C'était à
l'époque de la grande URSS.
- Le Kazakhstan était une des
républiques république
socialiste. Quand l'Union
soviétique a implosé, on a eu la
fédération de Russie qui a
demeuré, et puis les anciennes
républiques, beaucoup d'entre
elles ont formé des états
indépendants dans le Kazakhstan.
Ils se sont entendus rapidement
avec Moscou que Moscou continue
à utiliser cette immense base
spatiale qui est Baïkonour.
C'est vraiment étonnant. Ils ont
pu conserver donc ce qu'il
faisait à l'époque. Quand on
regarde la base, quand on suit
le programme américain depuis
des années, on sourit parce
qu'on se rend compte jusqu'à
quel point les Russes ont fait
les choses différemment. D'abord
la fusée Soyouz n'arrive pas à
la verticale comme les anciens
Saturn ou la navette spatiale,
ils arrivaient à la verticale.
Le Soyouz arrive coucher sur un
train, sur un wagon de train
tout simplement. Quand on arrive
au pas de tir, elle est tout
simplement redressée dans la
position nécessaire pour le
décollage. On a vu les bras qui
étaient écartés. Il y en a
quatre qui vont tenir la fusée
jusqu'au décollage.
- C'est presque comme dépenses
qui la tiennent au sol
pratiquement. On va tout à coup
ouvrir.
- C'est par des contrepoids que
cela va s'ouvrir. Les Américains
avaient au fond une structure
verticale à côté de la fusée et
quand la fusée décollée, il
fallait déjà qu'elle commence à
s'écarter un tout petit peu de
la structure métallique pour ne
pas rentrer dedans. Les Russes
ont fait quelque chose de
différent. Ils ont dit : ce que
l'on va faire, c'est que les
bras qui retiennent la fusée,
justement on la faisait part,
les bras s'écartent comme une
fleur, comme des pétales de
fleurs. La fusée s'élève. C'est
de façon complètement différente
de concevoir le pas de tir.
C'est vraiment fascinant.
- Vous avez bien raison. Si on
recule 11 octobre, les Russes
ont rapidement analysé quel
étaient le problème. On l'a
fixé. C'est une tige de capteur
qui a été percuté au montage à
Baïkonour apparemment. Cette
hypothèse sur laquelle on
travaille. Si cela avait été
probablement la NASA, on serait
encore en comité sénatorial
d'enquête probablement pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé.
- Il y aurait une enquête
beaucoup plus longue et
tristement, il aurait
probablement eu mort d'hommes
parce que c'est ce qui est
arrivé dans le cas de
Challenger, une flamme est
sortie du propulseur d'appoint
parce que les joints
d'étanchéi ne fonctionnaient
pas bien quand il faisait très
froid. Le décollage avait été
fait dans une température trop
froide le caoutchouc de ce juin
d'étanchéité qui devenait
friable. La flamme est sortie,
et cela a explosé. Il y a eu un
dégât de 2h30 une enquête qui a
duré des mois et des mois. Dans
ce cas, les Russes étaient
certains de ce qui s'était
passé. Les Américains ont dû
sentir brasser par la vitesse à
laquelle ils ont dit : on
recommence. Mais ils ont
confiance. Ils ont dit oui. Les
Canadiens aussi. Ce qu'il faut
considérer, c'est qu'il y a
quand même quatre lancements de
fusées Soyouz depuis. Trois
n'étaient pas tout à fait le
même modèle transporter des
satellites, mais le quatrième
qui a été envoyé le 16 novembre,
si je me souviens bien, c'était
la fusée identique à celle qui
va décoller aujourd'hui. Cela
s'est très, très bien passé.
C'était pour envoyer un
Progress, c'est une capsule
Soyouz qui Samarres
automatiquement. Tout s'est très
bien passé. Mais il y a quand
même eu cet incident qui avait
un petit trou dans la partie
habitable. Le Soyouz est
actuellement ancré à la Station
spatiale internationale. C'est
pas toujours comment cela s'est
fait. On pense que c'est une
foreuse qu'il a faite.
Probablement au sol quand le
tout a été construit ou
assemblé. Ça été bloqué par de
la colle Epoxy, c'est suffisant.
Ils ont des méthodes simples
pour ce genre de choses. La
partie habitable ne revient pas
dans l'atmosphère. C'est-à-dire
qu'elle revient, mais elle est
détruite. Les astronautes ne
sont pas abords. Il se sépare de
cette sphère.
- On nous indique maintenant
qu'il y a de l'action à l'Agence
spatiale canadienne. Nous allons
à l'écouter d'ailleurs les
dirigeants qui prennent la
parole.
- Cela fait plaisir de vous
accueillir en si grand nombre et
de partager avec nous ce moment
historique dans le programme
spatial canadien. Sans plus
tarder, j'aimerais vraiment vous
présenter un invité spécial qui
est avec nous. C'est un honneur
et un privilège pour nous
d'avoir l'honorable
Navdeep Bains, le ministre de
l'Innovation et du Développement
économique. Veuillez vous
joindre à nous.
(applaudissements)
- Merci. merci pour cette
présentation, pour votre accueil
chaleureux.
En ce matin, très tôt, mais
très intéressant pour moi, c'est
unique de vivre l'expérience en
direct de lancement et du départ
d'un astronaute canadienne dans
l'espace. Je me sens privilégié
d'être ici aujourd'hui.
Comme vous pouvez voir, dans la
pièce ici, le Canada a une
longue histoire spatiale,
beaucoup de Canadiens sont fiers
de notre programme spatial.
Aujourd'hui est un moment
extraordinaire pour tous les
Canadiens, un moment dont je
vais parler avec ma jeune fille
qui n'a pas pu me rejoindre
parce qu'elle doit aller à
l'école. Mais nous allons
reparler de ce moment pour des
années.
Comment David ne se sent-il
alors qu'il se prépare pour un
voyage de toute une vie,
l'espace peut nous inspirer,
inspirer l'humanité à aspirer
plus haut. Ce défi que l'espace
nous encourage à dépasser les
limites du possible. Dans les
premières minutes après le
décollage, le Soyouz va déployer
des millions de CV. Il va
atteindre une vitesse orbitale
de presque 92 000 km à l'heure
et l'équipe va voyager deux
milles d'ici à Saint-Jean à
Terre-Neuve en moins de cinq
minutes.
Alors David va devenir le
neuvième Canadiens, le neuvième
astronaute canadien. Il passera
six mois dans l'espace abords du
laboratoire international. Je
sais que Bob a passé 187 jours.
Il va passer quelques jours de
plus que vous. Alors vous
allez... et durant cette
période, il conduira neuf
expériences dans le domaine de
la santé et quelques expériences
internationales. Il testera de
nouvelles technologies.
Il manoeuvra aussi le bras
spatial canadien.
À chacune des photos qu'il nous
emploiera, avec tous les
contacts qu'il aura avec nous,
et nous amènera dans cette
aventure extraordinaire. Dans
deux semaines, il y a deux
semaines, nous avons célébré le
20e anniversaire du laboratoire
spatial international. 20 ans de
collaboration pacifique dans le
projet d'ingénierie le plus
complexe probablement de
l'histoire humaine.
Cette station nous a permis de
comprendre comment travailler et
vivre ensemble dans l'espace.
Et je vais suivre la mission de
David dans sa manipulation des
robots, dans son test de
nouvelles technologies, et
particulièrement voir le drapeau
canadien sur son épaule qui va
encourager les jeunes Canadiens
à aller vers les étoiles.
Nous, décrire ce qu'il ressent,
en ce moment, personne n'est
mieux placée qu'une astronaute
qui est déjà allée en mission
quelqu'un qui suivra un jour ces
traces.
Alors c'est mon honneur absolu
de dire bienvenue à Bob, le
premier astronaute canadien,
et notre nouvelle astronaute,
une nouvelle recrue. Je les
invite à monter sur scène et à
partager avec nous les quelques
minutes qui s'en viennent.
(applaudissements)
Bonjour, tout le monde.
Je suis contente d'être ici pour
partager ce moment avec vous.
J'ai été choisie dans la
dernière campagne de recrutement
d'astronaute canadien en juillet
2018 et depuis je m'entraîne au
Texas.
- Bonjour. Je suis un ancien
astronaute de l'Agence spatiale
canadienne pour la dernière fois
que j'ai décidée que c'est la
dernière fois qu'une astronaute
canadien est allé dans l'espace.
C'était pour mon copain Chris
Hadfield.
Et aujourd'hui, c'est une
aventure particulière parce
qu'on a une autre astronaute
canadienne qui s'en va pour
l'espace. Je pense qu'on a
besoin d'avoir plus d'astronaute
canadien pour que je puisse
venir ici plus souvent!
- Alors, après une décennie de
préparation et d'entraînement,
David Saint-Jacques est prêt à
faire le voyage spatial. Cela
prend beaucoup de travail. Je
sais que pour lui, ça été un
rêve de toute une vie. Regardons
d'un peu plus près le genre
d'entraînement nécessaire.
- David Saint-Jacques s'envolera
vers la Station spatiale
internationale.
- Après une dizaine d'années de
préparation, des milliers
d'heures de formation et
d'entraînement, je suis sur le
point de réaliser un rêve.
- C'est en 2008 quelle aventures
de David Saint-Jacques pour
devenir un jour astronaute
débute.
Après un long processus de
sélection de plus d'un an au
mois de mai 2009, David Saint-
Jacques est recruté par l'Agence
spatiale canadienne. Il devient
officiellement astronaute
canadien.
- Quand j'ai appris que j'avais
été sélectionné, j'ai réalisé à
quel point c'était privilégier.
Peu de gens ont cette chance.
- Une formation pour acquérir
les connaissances nécessaires.
- Mon entraînement est exigeant,
complexe. Mais quelle aventure!
- C'est en mai 2016 qu'on
annonce que David Saint-Jacques
est affecté à une mission. C'est
officiel, David partira dans
l'espace.
- Je suis honoré de représenter
les Canadiens dans cette
mission. Vous m'avez choisi.
Vous m'avez formé. Vous
m'accordez votre confiance. Je
promets de faire de mon mieux
pour être à la hauteur de vos
attentes.
- David est affecté à sa
première mission. Doit suivre un
programme de formation sur
mesure pour préparer son séjour
dans l'espace.
- C'est une mission de six mois
à bord de la Station spatiale
internationale.
Depuis des mois, je partage mon
temps entre le Canada, l'Europe,
le Japon, la Russie et les
États-Unis me préparaient pour
ma mission spatiale.
- L'entraînement et la formation
de David sont officiellement
terminés.
- Je vais maintenant avoir la
chance de mettre en application
toutes les connaissances, les
compétences que j'ai acquises.
- Le 3 décembre 2018, c'est le
jour J. David Saint-Jacques va
s'envoler de Baïkonour au
Kazakhstan pour rejoindre la
Station spatiale internationale.
- Je suis enfin prêt à me
rapprocher des étoiles. On se
revoit dans l'espace!
C'est la présentation directe
de l'Agence spatiale canadienne.
Charles, il y en a une qui se
dit, elle voit ce que cela peut
représenter, neuf ans de
travail. Mais on entend le
ministre, quand il dit que ça
prend plus de Canadiens, mais
tout une fonction du fait que ce
sont les Russes qui lancent
maintenant les astronautes et
les cosmonautes. Il y a moins de
place, il n'y a pas de programme
américain dans le moment. Au
moment où on se parle.
- On aurait plus astronautes
plus rapidement dans l'espace,
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment, ce
sont les Russes qui sont les
seuls à pouvoir lancer des êtres
humains en orbite. Mais il y a
quand même d'autres solutions
qui sont en préparation. Il y a
SpaceX. Il y a une capsule qui
devrait pouvoir si tout va bien
ici environ un an peut-être
moins commencé à transporter des
astronautes américains. Aussi à
sa capsule sur laquelle il
travaille. Elle est moins
avancée que le Dragon,
voilà.
- David Saint-Jacques se trouve
dans la capsule tout en haut
de cette fusée. On aura
l'occasion de revenir là-dessus
bien sûr au cours des prochaines
minutes. Le lancement est dans
moins de 15 minutes maintenant.
On est rendu à 1,5 fois la
gravité terrestre. Le poids a
été augmenté. Déjà à deux
minutes 20 secondes, les forces
G montent à 3,5. Le vaisseau et
la fusée vont rencontrer des
résistances très fortes.
- On accélère encore à cette
vitesse?
- Oui, on continue à accélérer.
Vous avez totalement raison,
c'est l'accélération qui cause
les forces G. On est dans
l'espace, peut pas boire un
verre d'eau tranquillement, mais
ça ne s'écrase pas contre le
mur. C'est quand on donne un
coup d'accélérateur dans notre
voiture, on sent la pression sur
le dos, c'est ce qu'on appelle
la force G.
- Une autre question pour vous,
Charles. Quelle est la vitesse
au décollage?
- La vitesse au décollage varie
évidemment. Déjà à quelques
secondes depuis l'décollage, on
atteint des vitesses
progressivement de plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres, 9000, 13
000, jusqu'à 27 000 à peu près
700 km. Ça se fait en neuf
minutes.
- C'est fantastique.
- Quand on parle de la vitesse
zéro à 100 km à l'heure, ça
prend cinq ou six secondes dans
un bolide. On va à 27 000 km la
en neuf minutes.
- Cela fait rêver. Merci pour
les questions. Continue à nous
faire parvenir vos questions
comme ça. Ça va animer notre
discussion. Probablement les
propos parce qu'on va retrouver
Kim Vermette qui se trouve au
collège de Maisonneuve. C'est là
où à étudier d'ailleurs David
Saint-Jacques. On va suivre
l'événement des prêts.
- Oui. Évidemment, Marc André,
il y a beaucoup de fébrilité. On
a très hâte d'assister à ce
lancement. Il y a une centaine
de personnes qui sont attendues
ici, des étudiants, des employés
du collège, des parents. Il y a
même des élèves qui ont dormi
cette nuit pour être certains de
ne rien manquer de ce grand
lancement parce que vous l'avez
dit, David Saint-Jacques a
étudié ici en sciences de la
nature. Il a obtenu son diplôme
en 1989. Ce que je vais vous
dire va peut-être vous
surprendre, c'est le premier
diplômé du collège de
Maisonneuve à s'envoler dans
l'espace. Alors évidemment ici
c'est une source de fierté. J'ai
parlé à quelques étudiants qui
voulaient venir assister au
lancement, on peut les écouter.
- Je suis un passionné de
l'espace. C'est la première fois
que j'assiste à un événement
aussi grand. C'est pour ça que
je suis ici ce matin.
- Je suis un passionné aussi de
l'astronomie. David Saint-
Jacques, c'est une personne
toute simple. Je l'ai vu
plusieurs fois de ma vie, il est
venu donner des conférences. Il
est venu à cette école. Quand
même, j'ai un lien avec lui. Je
trouve que de venir le voir
quand il s'en va dans sa mission
spatiale.
- C'est une personne quand même
accessible. C'est aussi quelque
chose d'exceptionnel, quand tu
sais tout le triage qu'il y a
pour arriver à cette position
d'être la personne qui décolle,
c'est exceptionnel.
- Il y a également sur place de
professeurs qui ont brièvement
enseigné à David Saint-Jacques.
Évidemment, ils sont très
excités ce matin de se trouver
sur place et d'assister à ce
grand lancement. On leur parlera
plus tard pour une autre raison
pour le collège de Maisonneuve
d'être très bien, c'est que ce
petit drapeau du collège de
Maisonneuve que vous voyez aura
sa place dans l'espace parce que
David Saint-Jacques l'a à bord
de ces balises. Voilà, une
centaine de personnes sont
attendues ici ce matin. On leur
a offert le déjeuner pour
l'occasion. Il se dirige
tranquillement dans la salle et
évidemment de l'occasion de vous
revenir avec toutes les
réactions une fois que le
lancement se sera déroulé.
- Le registre est mieux d'être
prêt au collège de Maisonneuve
parce que le programme Sciences
de la nature va peut-être avoir
un petit boost. On a hâte
d'entendre les professeurs de ce
neuvième astronaute canadien.
Nous sommes à plus du décollage.
Comme vous ne le disions, on
voit les astronautes, vous allez
nous les situer probablement. Je
crois qu'ils sont bien en place.
Ils sont fin prêts à partir dans
quelques minutes maintenant.
- Celui qui est au centre, c'est
Oleg Kononenko, c'est le pilote.
À sa gauche, c'est David Saint-
Jacques. Et puis Anne McClain et
de l'autre côté, à droite du
commandant. Ce qui est
intéressant, c'est que le
commandant doit appuyer sur les
boutons, on ne le voit pas
maintenant, mais il a une tige,
une baguette. Il est un peu trop
loin. Alors il est très
entraîné, il appuie sur le
bouton avec sa tige. Les autres
peuvent le faire manuellement,
exactement avec leurs doigts. On
voit la fusée. C'est
impressionnant parce que vous
savez, fusée des 90 % du
carburant. Il y a 310 t de
carburant sous les astronautes.
C'est une configuration la plus
sécuritaire possible quand la
capsule est au-dessus des
réservoirs. Les astronautes sont
beaucoup plus protégés que par
exemple dans le cas de la
navette ou les astronautes été
dans la navette, collé, on peut
dire que les astronautes étaient
collés sur le réservoir.
- On pouvait dire que dans
l'navette américaine, l'équipage
était à peu près , presque à la
demie.
- Facilement au-dessus de la
demie. Ils étaient dans la
cabine de pilotage. C'est une
configuration plus classique et
plus sécuritaire pour les
Américains d'ailleurs sont
revenus à cette configuration.
Il faut savoir que là encore,
l'approche des Russes est
différente. Cette fusée à une
grappe de propulseurs, quatre
propulseurs d'appoint qui
entoure la fusée à sa base. On
voit toujours les astronautes et
le cosmonaute russe qui sont
très calmes, très serein, face a
ce décollage. C'est vraiment
impressionnant de voir cela. Au
tout début, les moteurs à la
base même du corps principal de
la fusée s'allument. Les quatre
propulseurs d'appoints qui sont
en grappe tout autour s'allument
également. Et puis la fusée ne
lève pas tout de suite. Cela
prend une dizaine de secondes
peut-être même un peu plus pour
que la puissance arrive à son
maximum.
- On chauffe les moteurs.
- On s'assure que toutes les
pressions sont bonnes, que les
ponts qui vont chercher le
kérosène, parce que c'est un
véhicule qui est animé par de
l'oxygène liquide et du
kérosène, que le kérosène et
l'oxygène liquide arrive
ensemble à la bonne pression
pour que justement l'étincelle
qui se fait à la base allume le
tout et que la pression de cette
explosion contrôlée soit
parfaite. À ce moment-là,
on va voir Soyouz s'élever dans
le ciel. Ça va aller de plus en
plus vite. On va voir les bras
mécaniques écartés. Ils le font
par gravité, encore une solution
simple, des contrepoids
simplement. On risque pas une
défaillance de moteur puisque se
fait par la bonne vieille
gravité terrestre. Toute cette
mission, c'est un ballet entre
les machines, les humains et la
gravité terrestre.
- Ce sera en plusieurs étapes,
en profite aussi, peut-être que
vous pouvez donner des détails,
chars, mais d'abord ce que l'on
verra de tomber...
- c'est environ à deux minutes
qu'on va voir les propulseurs.
Se détacher du corps principal
de la fusée.
- Ils tombent en croix.
Il y a une caméra installée.
- C'est un moment critique. Il
faut que la libération se passe
bien. Faut que la fusée puisse
continuer son ascension sans les
propulseurs d'appoint.
- Il y a d'autres étages qui
sont largués progressivement
aussi, à peu près à 4 minutes
48.
- Et quatre minutes plus tard,
troisième étage va pouvoir
s'éteindre et se séparer du
Soyouz proprement dit. Cela
comprend trois unités, trois
éléments comme on le sait, la
parti habitable, la partie
pilotée et la partie technique
également. Donc, c'est le
vaisseau Soyouz qui va être
séparé du troisième étage
lorsqu'on arrivera près des neuf
minutes de vol.
---
- Tamara nous disait tantôt que
le décollage C6 heures 31 et 58
secondes.
À ce moment les ordinateurs et
ses consoeurs sont prêts.
Tout à coup on va donner le
signal et l'ordinateur prendra
le contrôle de ce lancement.
Toujours des moments excitants,
passionnants je ne sais pas si
ce sera seulement quand russe
mais on va aller écouter les
toutes dernières communications
avant le départ de David Saint-
Jacques pour les étoiles.
(silence)
- c'est très serein en ce moment
il n'y a même pas de
communication entre la capsule
et le sens de contrôle ce qui
est assez remarquable. Afin de
notre point de vue en nous, on
n'entend pas on peut présumer
cela.
- C'est sûr qu'on a fait toutes
les vérifications avant les
directeurs de vol, les
directeurs...
- c'est extrêmement complexe.
(en anglais)
- alors on nous a indiqué qu'on
va retirer.
Les bras.
(ena anglais)
un moment critique ils sont sur
leur propre énergie ils sont
sous séparés de l'énergie
générale. Le véhicule est
autonome.
(en anglais)
10 secondes.
Le moteur s'élance.
- On s'écarte
- Lift uoff.
- Anne McClain, David Saint-
Jacques
et Oleg Kononenko.
(en anglais)
tout se passe bien jusqu'à
présent.
- Tout se passe bien à
l'intérieur.
30 secondes et tout semble
encore bien aller.
- 1,5 g à ce stade.
- Tous les paramètres sont bons,
c'est ce qu'on nous indique tout
est normal.
Donc prochaine étape, surveillez
bien, les propulseurs.
- 1100 mille à l'heure.
- Une minute 30 secondes.
- On est à 2 g.
- Surveillez bien dans quelques
secondes, vous allez voir les
quatre propulseurs d'appoint
être largué. C'est calme dans la
cabine, dans la capsule.
Pas de souci.
- Alors voilà on voit la fusée
la caméra de la fusée.
(en russe)
(en anglais)
- on a largué les propulseurs.
- Et la coiffe du Soyouz qui
protège de l'espace a été largué
également. Le sommet de la
fusée.
On voit le compartiment
protecteur a été largué.
Là on est dans la partie de
résistance importance pour les
astronautes, ils subissent au-
delà de trois g.
Tout se passe très bien.
- Chaque fois que vous entendez
le mot «nominal»...
et dans une minute il y aura
donc une autre page qui sera
larguée.
- Exact.
(en anglais)
(en russe et en anglais)
on approche du moment où le
second étage va se séparer.
Le troisième étage va se
déclencher d'secondes avant que
le deuxième étage se détache.
Ce qui est assez remarquable.
- On a confirmation d'une bonne
séparation du deuxième étage
avec le troisième étage.
- Les astronautes subissent des
pressions considérables
également, c'est une étape
critique vient d'être franchi.
- Je vous rappelle qu'ils sont
dans cette phase d'ascension
avant d'en arriver à l'orbite,
ça dure quelque chose comme neuf
minutes alors en décollant à 32
minutes, il reste encore trois
minutes et demi.
Donc on écoute attentivement en
haut, à gauche au collège de
Maisonneuve et à l'agence
spatiale aussi, bien des gens
font des calculs et et avec leur
expertise peut-être qu'il voit
les choses différemment et
d'entendre également.
- On est à plus de 13000,14 km
1000 km/h, plus de 70 km
d'altitude.
Tout va bien à bord, on le sent
très bien.
- Ils ont déjà communiqué,
ils disent qu'il n'y avait aucun
problème de leur côté.
- C'est étonnant de voir jusqu'à
quel point
ce voyage est calme pour les
astronautes, ce qui n'est pas le
cas de certaines autres fusils.
Ce sont des cas très stables
avec peu de ...
- il y en avait qui faisait des
cercles et OGM, j'ai vu aux
déçus de David Saint-Jacques que
ne pas bouger du tout. Pour
combattre la gravité, est-ce que
les astronautes, cosmonautes
sont soumis à un régime spécial
avant de partir?
- Non mais évidemment ils
doivent être en excellente forme
physique parce que le corps
subit des pressions auxquelles
on n'est pas habitué sur terre.
Mais c'est surtout leur
entraînement et leur condition
physique qui leur permet de
résister à ce genre de chose.
Et bien sûr ce matin ils ont été
dans beaucoup de tests qui leur
permet de s'habituer,
l'accélérateur des astronautes
notamment.
(en anglais)
très important...
alors ça, ça va être moment
critique.
Quand ils arriveront à une
minute 45 secondes et vont
pouvoir se séparer du troisième
étage de la fusée.
( en russe)
quelques secondes encore avant
(en anglais)
- extraordinaire.
(en anglais et en russe)
- Charles est-ce qu'on se trouve
maintenant dans les temps la
mini station spatiale on a la
capsule et une espèce de
compartiment à l'arrière, on est
en orbite?
- Là ils approchent du moment ùu
ils sont satellisés ou encore
ils sont déjà satellisés. Voilà
ils ont atteint l'orbite et vous
parliez des petits nounours, là
ils vont flotter maintenant.
C'est pour ça qu'ils les mettent
là, dès que les voir flotter ils
savent qu'ils sont en
apesanteur.
Là ils ont atteint l'orbite. Ce
qu'il va falloir déterminer
maintenant ces si ils ont
atteint l'orbite visée.
(en anglais et en russe)
parce qu'encore une fois, s'ils
atteignent l'orbite visée ils
peuvent rejoindre la station
spatiale internationale en six
heures.
(en russe et en anglais)
en principe, les antennes et les
panneaux solaires vont se
déployer.
Les panneaux solaires évidemment
portent de l'électricité, de
l'énergie au vaisseau. Les
antennes leur permet de
communiquer.
(en russe et en anglais)
(en anglais)
- alors tout indique qu'ils ont
atteint l'orbite visée.
- Si le commandant a pu voir de
l'espace le décollage ça veut
dire qu'ils étaient suffisamment
près.
- Le décollage s'est fait par
mes vêtements au bon moment, ce
qu'on savait, ce donc on devait
être certain, c'est que les
moteurs avaient été à la
puissance voulue et la durée
voulue on a eu un début de
confirmation par le
communicateur ici à la NASA. Qui
nous indique que ces six heures
pour atteindre la station
spatiale internationale à partir
de maintenant. Ça c'est très
rassurant, syndic qu'ils ont
atteint l'orbite voulue. Ils ont
90 minutes pour s'assurer que
tous les systèmes fonctionnent
bien. Et qu'ils vont pouvoir
effectuer ce rendez-vous avec la
station spatiale internationale.
C'est très important, il faut
s'assurer que tout est «nomina»"
comme on dit parce qu'encore une
fois s'il y a un problème ils
ont plein de solutions possibles
mais tout indique que ça va
bien.
- On a une rotation de 90
minutes alors dans ses en 80
minutes on trouvait quelque
chose on pourrait enclencher le
mécanisme revenir sur terre.
- Oui, il y a toujours la
possibilité de séparer la
capsule qu'ils habitent
actuellement qui est pilotable
avec un bouclier thermique et
qui leur permettrait de revenir
dans l'atmosphère et de se poser
sur terre.
Donc je pense que la maintenant
ils sont dans une situation qui
est vraiment sécuritaire, et
tout indique que la mission se
déroule tel que prévu. Il n'y a
pas lieu de penser qu'ils ne
vont pas pouvoir entamer le
rendez-vous tel que prévu. Ce
sont des vérifications qui sont
tout à fait normales,
régulières, et qui font parti de
leur travail habituel pour
s'assurer qu'ils peuvent ensuite
entamer l'étape suivante. Tout
se fait par étapes évidemment.
- On attend d'une minute à
l'autre le point de presse de
l'agence canadienne, qui est
tout cela et qui est aux
commandes et à l'écoute.
Et qui suit l'évolution de ce
dossier, dès qu'ils seront en
mesure de nous en dire davantage
on pourra le faire. Quand on
pense à tous ces préparatifs
Charles initialement il devait
préparer le 20 décembre, et là
on a dit qu'on allait décoller
et qu'on allait devancer les
choses. Un vol commercial a
devancé de 17 jours imaginez-
vous aller dans l'espace et ça
se fait facilement.
- Très surprenant pour les
Américains et les Canadiens.
D'habitude les choses ont
beaucoup, ça prend plus de
temps. Il faut dire que les rues
sont tellement ce l'habitude de
ce système. Ils exploitent le
Soyouz depuis les années 60
c'est toujours la même fusée qui
a été améliorée, c'est toujours
le même concept. Alors ils ont
pu ciblé le problème qu'ils ont
eu au mois d'octobre habilement
et ils sont certains qu'il a été
corrigé. Parce qu'il fallait se
poser trois questions, qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé, pourquoi ça
s'est passé et peut-on prévenir
et s'assurer que ça ne se
reproduira pas. Quand ils ont
répondu à ces trois questions,
ils ont dit on n'y va. Les
Américains ont dit OK, on vous
suit. Et jusqu'à maintenant les
choses se sont très bien
déroulées.
- C'est naturellement un moment
de réjouissance pour tous ces
gens de l'agence qui sont
photographiés à côté
de cette image de David Saint-
Jacques.
- Et ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que suite à ce que vous venez de
mentionner, le fait que les
dates étaient échangées, ça veut
dire qu'il y a deux astronautes
de moins là-haut, deux
astronautes qui n'ont pas pu se
rendre. S'ils avaient eu pu s'y
rendre désirent il y aurait cinq
astronautes et l'équipage actuel
aurait été aurait remplacé
l'équipage de trois astronautes
revenues sur terre. Alors les
deux qui ont auraient dû y aller
auraient été là, ça fait cinq.
Et ça prend au moins cinq
astronautes pour faire tout
l'entretien du vaisseau spatial
et les tests scientifiques
aussi. Ça prend au moins trois
astronautes sur une base
régulière pour entretenir les
systèmes. S'assurer que tout
fonctionne bien. Ils ne seront
plus que...
- il en manquera deux.
- Vont-ils pouvoir faire toutes
les expériences scientifiques il
y a?. Et c'est le côté un peu
décevant dans ce qui s'est passé
en octobre. Il va manquer 2
coéquipiers à partir de
maintenant. À partir du 20
décembre parce que les autres
vont revenir le 20 décembre
les trois qui sont en surplus
vont revenir le 3 décembre. On
pense qu'il y a trois mois un
nouvel équipage va revenir. Pour
au moins trois mois ils vont
seulement êtr trois.
C'est le genre de vaisseau qu'il
faut entretenir continuellement.
- On va tout de suite se rendre
à l'agence spatiale canadienne
qui vont nous donner les
premières impressions, ce
neuvième Canadiens qui se trouve
dans l'espace.
- Alors notre gouvernement
soutient le programme spatial,
c'est un point de fierté pour
beaucoup de Canadiens.
David Saint-Jacques a été une
inspiration pour beaucoup de
jeunes et c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement canadien va
dépenser un demi milliard de
dollars dans le programme
spatial depuis 2015.
(inaudible)
alors de notre point de vue
aujourd'hui, c'est un exemple de
l'importance de ce programme
pour inspirer les jeunes
canadiennes et canadiens. Nous
avons plusieurs astronautes de
premier plan, ils veulent parler
du programme spatial, nous
travaillons sur une stratégie
spatiale, sur un programme
spatial et nous avons une
rencontre très positive et très
productive avec les
administrateurs de la NASA alors
on se voit impliquer dans
l'aventure spatiale provient des
années encore et nous allons
continuer de soutenir.
(en francias)
L'espace représente beaucoup
d'opportunités pour beaucoup de
Canadiens, particulièrement pour
nos enfants. Aujourd'hui David
Saint-Jacques,
il était une incroyable
expérience pour moi.
Et je suis très, très confiant,
nous allons continuer à aider et
continuer à aider le programme
pour l'espace.
Et comme j'ai disais en tant que
père de deux jeunes filles, ce
programme est une source
d'inspiration. Et je crois que
Jennifer Sidey-Gibbons et Bob
peuvent en parler en tant
qu'astronaute. Je crois que
c'est une source de fierté pour
tous les Canadiens et
Canadiennes, nous avons une
histoire spatiale et c'est un
moment de célébrer cette
histoire, nous célébrons le 20e
anniversaire de la station
spatiale internationale, c'est
très important pour nos enfants
et aussi les bénéfices qui
découlent de ce programme.
Beaucoup de recherche dans le
domaine de la santé, comme
Jennifer a mentionné, sur le
coeur, les os, le système
circulatoire mais aussi la
technologie comme le bras
Canadiens, on voit des impacts
positifs directs commande les
recherches à améliorer
l'industrie. Alors on a des
implications réelles, des
impacts réels de tout ce
programme spatial aident à
améliorer.
- David Saint-Jacques avait un
rêve de voler dans l'espace un
rêve incroyable et aujourd'hui
maintenant c'est vrai.
David est dans l'espace et il
commence ce travail pour le
reste du Canada. Il inspire les
jeunes Canadiens de suivre une
formation dans les sciences et
aussi d'inspirer la société
canadienne poursuivre les choses
difficiles.
- Je vais moi souligner
l'importance d'avoir ces
modèles, ces modèles qui
réalisent leurs rêves comme
David l'a fait aujourd'hui,
c'est important pour moi.
Et si les programme social
canadien n'avait pas existé, ce
voyage va nous apporter beaucoup
de nouvelles connaissances. Mais
simplement ce qu'on a vu ce même
matin, ce décollage, c'était
incroyable.
- L'horaire est très occupé à
bord de la du vaisseau spatial,
chaque seconde est prévue et
planifiée, et fait partie
d'honoraires.
Et David va devoir accomplir le
travail, faire à son rythme les
choses mais il doit aussi
conserver de ses son énergie
physique et psychologique pour
accomplir toutes ces tâches.
Quand j'étais dans l'espace le
plus difficile c'était d'être
éloigné de ma famille de la
planète. Mais son travail va
avec la technologie à bord de la
station spatiale internationale
va lui permettre d'avoir des
contacts avec sa famille et il
va pouvoir se concentrer sur le
travail à faire.
J'ai manqué même famille,
c'était difficile de voler dans
l'espace de faire des choses
professionnelles pour le
programme international de la
station spatiale et aussi de
continuer à fonctionner comme
père, et époux.
- Alors voilà un beau point de
presse, des gens qui se sont
très inspirés. Notamment
Jennifer Sidey-Gibbons une
spécialiste des combustions et
carburant. Les gens vont peut-
être quitter et suivre les
actualité spatiale. Quelle est
la prochaine étape qu'on doit
regarder, voir comme cruciale?
- Ça va être bien sûr le rendez-
vous, s'assurer que le Soyouz
puisse rejoindre la station
spatiale internationale et
pouvoir s'amarrer. La procédure
d'amarrage est extrêmement
difficile à réaliser, délicate
et ça se fait automatiquement.
Lorsqu'il n'y a pas de problème
de l'ordinateur tout va très
bien. L'étape suivante c'est les
coûts l'ouverture des écoutilles
pour aller visiter la nouvelle
maison. On frappe sur
l'écoutille. Ils vont se devoir
s'assurer que tout est bien
pressurisé, qu'il n'y a pas de
petite fuite, dans les eaux
d'étanchéité qui pourrait
déclencher une différence de
pression, ça prend une heure à
deux pour faire ça. Et quand ce
sera fait, ils vont taper sur la
porte, les autres vont répondre
les écoutilles vont s'ouvrir et
ils vont s'embrasser.
- Très bien, tout le monde va
être content, vers midi 31 cet
arrimage. Alors on vous laisse
aller, et on vous remercie
d'être avec nous ce matin. On va
vous retrouver un peu plus tard
ce matin pour résumer tout cela,
voir tout où nous en serons un
peu plus tard ce matin. On
parlera également à Tamara
- Décollage réussi pour David
St-Jacques et ses coéquipiers!
Les trois astronautes sont en
route vers la Station spatiale
internationale!
- Je trouve que j'ai un lien
avec lui, puis je trouve
seulement que venir le voir
quand il s'en va dans sa mission
spatiale...
- D'être la personne qui
décolle, c'est exceptionnel.
- Amis, collègues, et étudiants
ont suivi le décollage en
direct. C'est un rêve qui
devient réalité pour
l'astronaute canadien.
- Le gouvernement de la CAQ
dépose sa première mise à jour
économique. Y aura-t-il des
baisses d'impôt pour les
Québécois?
- Encore quelques précipitations
verglaçantes. Si on se déplace
un peu à l'est, le vent va se
lever, porte de la Nouvelle-
Écosse, ce sera vente de ce
côté. On aura des températures
qui seront à la baisse à bien
des endroits aujourd'hui.
(en anglas)
Des images de la fusée Soyouz,
qui transporte l'astronaute
canadien David Saint-Jacques
vers la Station spatiale
internationale.
La fusée a décollé il y a
30 minutes du Cosmodrome de
Baikonour, au Kazakhstan.
À ses côtés dans le vaisseau,
se trouvent l'astronaute
américain Anne McLain et le
cosmonaute russe Oleg
Kononenkov.
Le vaisseau Soyouz doit
s'arrimer avec la Station
spatiale internationale plus
tard cet après-midi.
David St-Jacques devient
le premier Canadien à orbiter
la terre depuis Chris Hadfield.
Cela devait être un moment de
grande émotion, pour les gens
présents.
- Oui, de l'émotion et du
silence radio. Pas seulement
pendant le décollage, mais
jusqu'aux minutes la fusée a
besoin pour se rendre en orbite.
C'est seulement quand on a
annoncé que la fusée était en
orbite, exactement neuf minutes
après son décollage, on a éclaté
de joie. Des applaudissements,
les familles en larmes. Ça
voulait dire que les astronautes
étaient hors de danger. Ils sont
en train de faire le tour de la
terre. Ils en feront quatre
avant de s'amarrer à la Station
spatiale internationale. On a pu
parler pour la première fois
depuis trois jours, on voit la
femme de David Saint-Jacques
avec ses trois enfants, elle
circule dans Baïkonour, elle
parle à son mari à travers une
vitre, des moments émouvants est
difficile pour elle. On a pu lui
parler, il était avec Julie
Payette. Elle a dit à quel point
elle est contente de savoir que
David Saint-Jacques, il est là
où il voulait être au moment où
on se parle, ce sont des moments
exceptionnels, privilégié de
pouvoir y assister. Le travail
commence, une mission de six
mois et demi. Ce sera la plus
longue pour un Canadien à bord
de la Station spatiale
internationale, on aura
l'occasion de lui parler dès ce
soir. Il a promis, une fois
entrée dans la Station spatiale
internationale, d'entrer en
communication avec la terre une
conversation, une première.
- Ils ont des accès privilégiés
à certaines périodes de la
journée. On est relativement en
contact. Vous savez à quoi cela
crée longuement en Floride quand
une fusée ou une navette était
lancée. Est-ce que l'on voit la
même chose dans la population
autour de Baïkonour?
- Baïkonour n'existe que pour
cela. Les gens qui sont ici sont
habitués. S'il n'y avait pas de
fusée, Baïkonour a déjà été un
grand village de pêcheurs, c'est
une ville qui s'est développée
autour des  laboratoire secret
et ensuite du programme spatial.
Ce sont des outils ici. On ne
peut pas, je viens de le vivre
pour la première fois, on ne
peut pas être insensible à voir
des humains décollés dans un
tube de métal, ce n'est pas
seulement un tube de métal, mais
c'est comme un missile, le
Soyouz. Ça n'a rien à voir avec
la navette spatiale des
Américains. Les couleurs sont
différentes personnes que la
terre tremble, le bruit est
intense. C'est sous nos yeux.
C'est absolument exceptionnel à
voir. Pour les gens qui ont
l'habitude de voir, c'était le
silence radio. Tout le monde
retenait son souffle. Ce sont de
grands moments. Pour le Canada
qui envoie seulement un
astronaute aux six ans, cinq
ans, c'est important.
- Tout à fait, vous avez raison.
On continue à vous suivre. Vous
allez continuer à faire de la
cueillette et nous faire
parvenir d'autres témoignages.
On attend de vos nouvelles.
Merci Tamara Alteresco. À plus
tard.
- Ça me fait plaisir. Au revoir.
Tous sont très fiers d'avoir
assisté à ce grand moment,
Pascal Robidas.
- Il fallait entendre les
applaudissements dans la salle
de conférence de l'Agence
spatiale canadienne quand
l'ancien astronaute Robert
Thirsk a annoncé que David
Saint-Jacques était un
astronaute alors que la capsule
Soyouz est officiellement entrée
en orbite autour de la terre.
Des gens extrêmement fiers. Tous
les employés de l'agence
spatiale ont assisté à ce
décollage vers 6h31, heure de
l'Est. Décollage sans faute qui
vol en ramenant les astronautes
par parachutage. David Saint-
Jacques est officiellement
autour de la terre. Il va
effectuer quatre tours complets,
quatre tours de 90 minutes avant
de se mettre en orbite et dans
la même position, la même
trajectoire que la Station
spatiale internationale, donc
dans 6 avril devrait être en
mesure de procéder à l'opération
d'arrimage. Il est le copilote
dans cette émission. David
Saint-Jacques fait également la
fierté à l'Agence spatiale
canadienne parce que comme
Tamara Alteresco l'a dit, il
s'envole vers l'espace, mais
c'est un homme qui a grandi à
Saint-Lambert, il est natif de
Québec, 48 ans. Évidemment, une
feuille de route très
impressionnant, astrophysicien,
physicien, médecin de famille.
Il s'est entraîné durant presque
10 ans pouvoir s'envoler vers ce
voyage de six mois et demi. On
vous a préparé les réactions du
ministre responsable de l'Agence
spatiale canadienne, Navdeep
Bains Hinse. On peut l'écouter.
NAVDEEP SINGH BAINS, ministre
Innovation, des Sciences
et du Développement économique
- L'espace représente beaucoup
d'opportunités pour tous les
Canadiens, particulièrement
pour nos enfants.
Aujourd'hui David Saint-Jacques,
il est... il a été une
incroyable expérience pour moi.
Et je suis très très confiant,
nous allons continuer à aider,
et continuer à aider
le programme pour l'espace.
- Alors David Saint-Jacques
concentrera ses efforts vers des
expériences en laboratoire. La
Station spatiale internationale
est un immense laboratoire. Il
se déplace à 28 000 km à l'heure
environ autour de la terre. Il
sera principalement l'objet de
ses propres recherches parce que
le programme spatial canadien et
concentré présentement sur les
effets de la pesanteur sur le
corps humain. On va étudier
entre autres le vieillissement
du corps humain. On sait que six
mois dans l'espace, cela
équivaut à 10 ans de vie humaine
sur terre. Comment le corps
réagit, ce sont des expériences
qui auront un impact dans la
recherche médicale.
- Des médicaments, des
traitements ultérieurement.
Merci Pascal. On vous retrouvera
plus tard.
Le gouvernement Legault dévoile
aujourd'hui sa toute première
mise à jour économique,
Andrée-Anne,
à quoi peut-on s'attendre?
- A des dépenses, mais aussi
de la prudence. Je pense que ç